&gt;&gt; All right, let's build off our knowledge from the last problem. &gt;&gt; We know
that here we had an equal sign here last time, so when this was equal x had to
be two. &gt;&gt; So there is one solution, but we don't have an equal sign here, we
have an in equality sign. &gt;&gt; So I want this right side to be larger than eight.
&gt;&gt; If x was two, I get eight. &gt;&gt; So that means if x was any number bigger than
two, then this side would be larger than eight. &gt;&gt; I'm going to try plugging in
3. &gt;&gt; If I plug in 3, I get 9 plus 2 on the right. &gt;&gt; So 8 is less than 11. &gt;&gt;
This is great. &gt;&gt; This is a solution that works. &gt;&gt; And in fact, any number
bigger than 3 would give me a number larger than 8 when I plug in. &gt;&gt; So,
there's gotta be more than one solution. &gt;&gt; There's not just 1 or 2, there's
infinitely many. &gt;&gt; There's more than three. &gt;&gt; If you choose this one, nice
work. &gt;&gt; You might be skeptical just looking at this one solution. &gt;&gt; Let me
show you four. &gt;&gt; When I plug in 4, I get 8 is less than 12 plus 2, or 8 is less
than 14. &gt;&gt; Plugging in any number bigger than 2, like 3 4 5 or even 500 would
work. &gt;&gt; That's why there's infinitely many solutions here.